hi in this video I will discuss our
technique known as c100 b100
centrifugation assay so this type of
assay is performed to detect whether a
protein is present in a membrane or in a
such a solid fraction so you might be
thinking that one protein is inducing
other protein to be localized in the
membrane so membrane localization of one
protein may be dependent on other
protein so if you ask this type of
question you could perform this kind of
essay to find the answer so the basic
principle of the assay is you have to
take the tissue lie set or the cell
lysate so in this particular case you
have taken the fly Lycett lyse it from a
Drosophila and you do the
ultracentrifugation after
ultracentrifugation you would get two
type of fraction one is membrane
fraction another in cytosolic fraction
as the cytosolic fraction is heavier you
would find the cytosolic fraction in the
bottom and the membrane fraction at the
top you differently collect membrane
fraction and cytosolic fraction after
collecting membrane fraction and
cytosolic fraction both are individually
loaded onto the protein gel you can see
in the protein gel you you would get you
would get different bands for membrane
brown fraction and for the systolic
fraction after that you would perform a
Western blot and you would use the
antibody against P because you want to
see whether protein B is localized in
the cytoplasm or B is localized in the
membrane so and this localized and
whether this localization is dependent
upon protein a so does protein a help
protein B to localize into the membrane
this is our question so you can see in
the there is a Western blot and in the
detailed western blot you can see there
is C which means the cytoplasmic
fraction
means membrane fraction and T means
total fraction so in the control
condition you can see the particular
protein B is present in both cytoplasm
and membrane fraction but still you can
see in the red box that means in the
cytosolic fraction the protein B is
mostly present and when you overexpress
protein a you would see in the yellow
box protein B is mainly present in the
membrane mount fraction but C in the
cytoplasmic fraction there is no protein
a protein B that means protein a is
actually helping protein B to localize
into the membrane again to prove it in
the reverse way we can do it we can do a
different experiment like we can knock
down protein a and in that knockdown
condition we can check the level of
protein B and you can see in this
condition protein bees present in the
cytosolic fraction mainly but not in the
membrane fraction so from these couple
of observation we can say that protein a
is actually helping protein B to be
localized into the membrane so this is a
utility of C 100 P 100 si if you liked
my video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to leave comments and thank you